congresswoman rashay becoming a major
headache for the Democratic party so far
top Democrats like hakee Jeff and Nancy
Pelosi have declined to condemn her
false claim that blames Israel for the
hospital blast in Gaza even though
initial us intelligence says
otherwise there's two of your colleagues
Congressman TB and Omar who have tweets
up saying that Hamas is to blame for the
hospital attack in Gaza should they
delete those tweets I've been very clear
in my position in standing behind Israel
as it relates to its right to defend
herself against the brutal terrorism of
Hamas so should they delete those tweets
seen tweets and without condemnation it
seems like SL is as bold as ever she's
now openly railing against her pro
Israel
colleagues I'm going to be real with you
all my colleagues many of them I usually
don't talk smack about them no I'm
usually considerate because I don't like
them policing me so I don't police them
but as an American not just as a member
of the United States Congress I am
ashamed I am ashamed that they're saying
not yet maybe next week congresswoman
Alan Omar is backtracking a little bit
after accusing Israel of striking the
hospital she's now blaming press reports
including the Associated Press for
spreading false information judge I feel
like you might be a little fired up
about this um just a hunch I have um but
is it fair to question leadership about
this I mean this happens on the GOP side
too you got some people out there saying
doing controversial things does the
leadership have to own and clarify
everything for those people well yeah I
think the American people want that I
think the truth is that you know for
Hakeem Jeff to say well I don't know
exactly what the Tweet said and
therefore he's not going to criti of
course he knows exactly what the Tweet
said but you know the Democrats are very
good at this I'm they're very trial they
just line up together and as it relates
to Rashida Talib I mean the woman loves
to hog the microphone unless somebody
asks her about Israeli children who've
been beheaded or are being burned alive
and then she of course runs down the
halls of the capital I think that um
this is something that is very emotional
for a lot of people the truth is the
most important part of all of this and
you know the the the the the the Press
is not helping in a lot of the world as
I said in the a block I mean they're
just promoting this lie so everybody
gets to go to their corners and just
spew whatever they want but I think that
Pelosi and Jeff I mean you recall ilhan
Omar in 2019 did that whole thing about
the Benjamins and the anti-semitic stuff
and Nancy Pelosi came in in 2019
defending her saying something like you
know she has a different experience in
the use of words but we're going to keep
her on the Foreign Relations Committee
even though she thinks and and speaks
differently um I I think that leaders
refusing to condemn what they know is
not the truth it it shows that they
shouldn't be leaders well and just I
mean there have been a number of people
in her own party who have come out and
like no no this is not for us we're not
going there right and to add on to what
the judge was talking about in 2019 she
did end up in the end defending her but
she called her out first had her delete
the Tweet Jamie Rasin issued a statement
Debbie wasman Schultz issued a statement
like Jews in the Democratic party
serving in Congress are not quiet about
these things there is no love lost
between them and Alan Omar and Rashida
Talib Ayanna Presley sometimes I I will
say that AOC has been much better about
this than what you typically expect as
the squad quote squad leader um but you
read um fedman statement it was
absolutely scathing right that it has to
come down you continue to promote with
false information how can you take the
word of Hamas after over our Democratic
Ally
um Rashida TB is just out over her skis
um with this one I think it will
backfire on her and you're even seeing
Rana Congressman a very liberal
Congressman um from California he
actually had someone resign from his
team because he refused to sign tb's uh
ceasefire proposal and he said you know
this guy was a great member of the team
it seems like it's not a good fit if
those are your politics they're not my
politics well and Jesse this has been a
very clarifying event for a lot of
people when comes to the college
campuses and statements from
administrators and all kinds of things
it's it's kind of it lets you know
exactly where people stand yeah it's
exposed a lot of people and I've been
happy to see people exposed and I'm glad
these donors are taking their money back
good to fund the universities what about
Omar though because she's different than
TB so Omar came out a couple years ago
and then Pelosi pulled her aside and
said you have to knock that off so she
kind of calmed down a little bit and
then she got booted from house Foreign
Affairs and she got censured and in this
time at least she learned a lesson
because she did pull back her statement
on social media tb's a different animal
you have she's Palestinian American
she's Muslim American she represents a
large Muslim Community in her District
she planted a Palestinian flag outside
of her office so this is very emotional
for her and she's connected but it
doesn't give her the right to lie and it
doesn't give her the right to push Hamas
propaganda so Jeff is going to have to
be able to one to deliver the message
Pelosi's not going to do it she's not
the top dog dog anymore he's the top dog
so he has to take her aside and tell her
to knock it off I don't think he's going
to be able to do it he doesn't have the
chops he's he's new at this doesn't have
the seniority or the stature and she's
radicalized you can see it in her eyes
she's radicalized you see her out there
she's almost
crying I don't think you're going to be
able to stop this runaway train I think
she's going to do permanent damage to
the Democrat caucus and her colleagues
are going to be upset Democrat donors
are going to be upset they have a Hamas
problem in the house well I mean gr do
you as the Democrat leadership do you
just write her off like hey she's off
and doing her own thing she doesn't
speak for us but we you know recognize
she has her own experience I don't think
it's a party matter at this point
permission to go off on a tangent all
right some liberals will say as Jessica
says that she holds no sway over the
party but it's not the party that steers
the culture it's the the reverse culture
steals the Party politics is Downstream
from culture Breitbart said that
unfortunately the Democratic party are
bystanders to a destructive movement
that they themselves encouraged
Democrats didn't Riot or loot either but
the mindset of Oppression that has
infected our culture has been egged on
by that party and that's where to Le
does damage it's not in our politics
it's actually in our entertainment it's
in our conversation it's wherever we go
it's why you can't be surprised and this
is where I will go off tangent by this
mentality there was a woman there's a
woman now in critical condition after
being pushed into a moving New York City
subway train in broad daylight this is
always a woman this isn't the second
third or fourth or fifth time and yet
the feminist liberals in New York City
there's nothing but silence nothing but
silence to them the real threat is
misgendering and so the silence was
always there the defense of the
oppressed was always there and it flows
from the same place which is this
oppression filter and this is why I
think you're seeing a lot of liberals
waking up Jewish Liberals are waking up
and finding themselves watching this
show or watching Fox because there's
nowhere else where sanity thrives but
here hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else